[Music]
how's it going good I live here in Los
Angeles and I was walking through my
neighborhood down the sidewalk and I was
passing this guy and right we were
passing each other right we were passing
each other he said to me ah little
titties I thought she was a man okay
okay if you think that and okay if you
say that to yourself but that thought
had to go through several layers of
filters in his mind and a checklist and
he still decided yeah I'm gonna need to
say this like think of all the things he
decided not to say things like good
afternoon
or um I was gonna say something but I
decided not to nope he went with them a
little titties I thought she was a man
[Laughter]
all my friends are having kids and um
they always send email updates
I love getting those I do what I can't
stand is when they include the question
can you believe it
Caitlyn is starting kindergarten this
year can you believe it I don't know I
mean what is she about five that sounds
about right
yeah I can believe that they were to
email me me like Caitlyn has never grown
any bigger since the day she was born
never spoken a word at all in her life
she's graduated from college today can
you believe it oh my god no I can't
believe that send more photos but can I
believe that Caitlyn is following the
natural progression of life yeah I can
totally wrap my head around that
do you guys like impressions oh good I
love when people do impressions they
tell you the name of the impression and
then one second later they tell you the
name of the impression again like you're
gonna forget so this is my impression of
a person doing impressions my impression
of a person doing impressions do you
guys like impressions
yeah
you do okay good this is my impression
of a person doing impressions my
impression of a person doing impressions
do you guys like impressions oh good
you're gonna like this this is my
impression of a person doing impressions
now I actually have three impressions
aside from that one that I just nailed
the first one is a spring a spring
please be quiet
spring don't you anyways and that's my
worst one there even better it goes it
goes up from here second impression is
curtains opening curtains opening
[Laughter]
that one's really pretty good my third
and final impression is a clown horn if
you don't like that then you just don't
want joy in your heart
that was fantastic
take the car
[Applause]
you